(dramatic music building to a climax)
- I don't think I've
ever touched your foot
in my hands before.
One time he recently fractured his foot
and wanted a foot massage
and I was very hesitant
so I massaged his hand instead.
(mysterious music)
(laughter)
Oh, man.
(laughs)
This is gonna be really hard.
I definitely don't think
this is Steve's foot.
It's a little sticky (laughs).
And I feel like Steve
also runs so he probably
has more on the bottom of his foot.
I definitely don't think
this is Steve's foot.
(laughs)
This one's definitely hairier.
Now I'm thinking that the other one
might have been closer to his foot.
Also feels like this guy uses lotion.
I'm pretty sure Steve doesn't use lotion.
I think this might be Steve's foot.
Actually I don't know,
this foot seems huge
compared to the other feet.
Now I'm starting to think
that maybe I was wrong
and maybe the first foot was Steve's foot.
I'm gonna go with number one.
Oh, turn around right now?
- Oh, definitely not Steve.
I do not even know who this kid is, hi.
- Hi.
- I'm Jen.
(laughs)
I really hope I'm right on this one.
I'm gonna guess number three.
(laughs)
Oh my god.
Oh, man.
So I failed.
(laughter)
- Lotioned up?
What was that business?
(laughter)
- So I guess Steve uses lotion.
- I don't use lotion.
Okay, you made the
first guess wrong, fine.
I was sure that I would be a close second
but not even close.
- In fact I'm actually
so relieved that it feels
like you wash your feet.
- I don't lotion up the feet, I don't.
(Jen laughs)
If you want me to start, I guess I could.
But again, you hate feet.
We don't spend all day--
- That was the first time
I've touched your feet
in three and a half years.
Either way, probably won't
ever touch your feet again.
(laughs)
But you won't touch my hand now?
(laughter)
- I don't wanna touch your hand.